so I want to talk about a case that's
pretty chilling especially on the heels
of the whole Starbucks thing and you
remember of course with that to black
people or escorted out of Starbucks in
Philadelphia by police after they
entered the establishment and sat down
at tables and refused to buy anything
even though the manager requested that
and told them if you want to stay here
you have to buy something and she even
offered to bring them bring to serve
them at the table you know she was she
was going out of her way to to enforce
the policy in a very polite way but they
refused to leave and they refused to buy
anything so she called the police only
thing she could do and then she was
fired for she was fired for or at least
she was removed from that Starbucks and
she was defamed by the CEO of Starbucks
all all for for following the policy and
following the rules and trying to
enforce the rules and and I can only
pray that she sues Starbucks I haven't
read anything about that manager suing
Starbucks but I hope that she sues them
into oblivion because I think she really
has quite a case but on the heels of
that episode we have this story out of
Oregon a pair of employees at Portland's
back to Eden bakery were fired
after after refusing to serve a black
woman okay that's the
that's that that's at least the headline
that you know that's that's the headline
that we're supposed to focus on is that
two people refused to serve a black
woman so clearly it's racism obviously
that's the only explanation I mean they
refuse to serve
but why do they refuse to serve her out
because the store was closed they
refused to serve a black woman after the
store was already closed and they were
fired for it okay this this actually
happened they were fired for the crime
of closing the store at closing time
so for a little context the store closed
at 9 o'clock at night
at 9:04 two customers walked in they
happened to be white and they were
informed that the store just closed and
so they were gonna be the last customers
this is pretty standard procedure if
you've ever been to a to a store right
at closing time or a minute after
closing time or a restaurant or bar or
something you may be told okay fine
you're the last one right very often the
first customers to come in right after
closing they will get the honor of being
the very last once and they'll be told
that or think about if you're in a
grocery line and the light has just
turned off but you you slide into the
line quickly and then many times the
cashier will say okay you're the last
one
so they were the last once they were
given that distinguished honor and that
a couple minutes after that another
woman woman walks in she happens to be
black and her name is Lillian green
she's informed that the women in front
of her are the last ones in the stores
closed so what does she do she proceeds
to take out a phone and start filming
and she starts filming and she accuses a
store of racism for refusing to serve
her after the store had already closed
this apparently is the first time she'd
ever encountered the concept of a closed
establishment she had never Lillian
green has never heard of stores closing
before she had no idea that that
happened she was shocked by it she
thought that all stores everywhere are
open all the time so she took a video
and she was and it went viral and very
quickly the employees were fired now
the bakery owner John Blomgren is his
name which just seems like a perfect
name for everything going on I don't
know why it just seems like the perfect
name
so Blomgren issues a lengthy statement
on Facebook which has since been deleted
for some reason he issues a lengthy
statement
talking about why why he fired the
employees and you know explaining the
whole situation and it's an incredible
it's a truly incredible statement so
Blomgren says that he says himself that
the employees who denied service to the
black woman who came in after closing
they are not racist he says that himself
he knows that they're not racist and he
knows they didn't have racist intentions
he knows that too yet and I'm quoting
here in this situation it doesn't really
matter because Lillian felt like she had
been discriminated against so she felt
like she had been discriminated against
so it doesn't really matter what was
intended all that matters is how this
woman felt about he goes on to say that
sometimes impact outweighs intent and
when that happens people need to be held
accountable
since both Lillian and the clamoring
public we're demanding that these staff
members be fired that is what we did
putting these two women out of work it
was an incredibly difficult thing for us
to do especially when they felt they
were just upholding our closing time of
9:00 p.m. but the way in which they went
about it lacked sensitivity and
understanding of the racial implications
at work
ah oh my gosh
so what do we have here and then by the
way Blomgren also also said in a
statement that's back to Eden bakery is
100% committed to being a welcoming and
supportive environment for all customers
who share our values of inclusivity and
dismantling the white supremacist hetero
patriarchy so it's not good or surprise
you to learn that this is a vegan bakery
by the way you probably won't be
surprised to learn that but that's not
the point the point is that he admits
that the employees didn't actually do
anything wrong
but all that really matters is how the
poor aggrieved Lillian feels about it
and he even admits that he fired his
employees because of the clamoring
public he went he came out and said yeah
I got rid of him because of the
pitchfork mob so that's what I did you
know what what else am I going to do the
right thing come on
so it matters what the clamoring public
wants according to Blomgren it matters
how Lilian feels what does it matter is
what actually happened that's the only
thing that doesn't matter here according
to Blomgren the only thing it doesn't
matter is the reality of the situation
that's what doesn't matter but the
hallucinations and the the delusions of
lily and green and the clamoring public
that's what matters so two innocent
employees had to lose their livelihood
as a sacrificial offering to the
aggrieved masses
now
how does this relate to
um
the situation in the culture generally
well because this whether it's this or
the Starbucks thing and I think you've
got a real precedent here with Starbucks
and with this I mean this is a really
dangerous president and it it certainly
is making me very thankful that I don't
work in the customer service industry
and then when you add in all the stuff
with the the Christian bakeries and the
LGBT mob that's been targeting them
we'll see what happens with the Supreme
Court case that that will be announced
in the next few weeks but a Supreme
Court finds against the Christian bakers
then we're really going to be in a
position where you just can't operate as
a business owner anymore in America
so this is the inevitable results when
people are empowered to interpret
something however they want to interpret
it and then impose that interpretation
on everyone else
that this is what happens so look at it
this way in any human conversation or
interaction there are basically three
things there are three factors at work
here so number one in any two anytime
something is said to another person
there's three factors number one
there is what is actually said okay so
that's one fact what did what was
actually said the second factor what was
meant what did the person mean when they
said it okay that's the second thing
third factor what did the person who was
being spoken to what did they hear how
did they interpret it those are the
three elements of any human exchange
right now things go really smoothly if
all three of those things line up if the
speaker means what he says and says what
he means and to hear here's what it said
it understands what is meant that's how
you have a successful human interaction
that's when you can give each other a
high five and say yes
we interacted as human beings in a
satisfactory manner because it's such
it's such a rare thing these days that
you really have to stop and appreciate
it when it happens but a breakdown
occurs when one of those three factors
falls out of step with everything else
when there's a disharmony among those
three factors so if what a person says
doesn't line up with what they mean
there's going to be a miscommunication
and if what a person hears doesn't line
up with what was said or what was meant
then there's a miscommunication but
here's the thing okay this is the this
is the really important point but I want
everyone to we all need to understand
if I speak clearly and honestly and I
use the appropriate language to convey
my meaning
and yet you hear something entirely and
completely different from what I said or
meant that's on you that's your fault
that's not my fault
I don't need to apologize for it I
shouldn't get fired for it
I'm not responsible for your
misinterpretation in that case I have
done my job I said what I meant I said
it clearly and that's all I can do now
the balls in your court
I cannot be held accountable for your
unwillingness or inability to understand
something that was clearly communicated
to you so if I say to you for instance
oh I'm sorry the store is closed for the
evening I can't serve you
that's a clear that if I say that that's
a very clear statement and any person
with at least more than seven or eight
brain cells in their head understands
what that means it's a very clear
clearly conveyed idea so if that's what
I say and that's what I mean
and that statement indeed reflects my
intentions and my meaning
and yet you here yet what you hear in
your head is we don't serve your card
here get out
this is for white people only
if that's how you hear it when all I
said was it was we're closed and you
hear that this is a store for white
people that we're segregated
well well that's your fault that's on
you I shouldn't be punished for it
you're the one who owes me an apology
for wildly misconstruing some very
simple statement you owe me you should
apologize to me I demand an apology from
you in that case because I did my job
you didn't do your job which was just
simply listening to what I said and
understand it so likewise if I say oh
these tables are for customers only I
need you to buy something if you're
gonna sit here which is what the
Starbucks manager said to the two black
gentlemen that were at the Philadelphia
Starbucks if I say that and you hear
only white people are allowed in
Starbucks
yet again that's on you that's your
fault you owe me an apology for
misconstruing what I said
I communicated my meaning and intention
as clearly as humanly possible yet you
snatched it out of the air and twisted
it into the weirdest little pretzel that
you could and then you beat me over the
head with it now I need the apology I am
the victim in that scenario not you
you're the bully
you
my only job in an exchange with you
is to convey my meaning clearly and
understand what's your only job is to
understand money
if I fail to be clear you know if I
communicate in a way that's very vague
and doesn't make a lot of sense then
your misunderstanding is my fault and I
owe you an apology
but if I do my job well and if I do
everything I can on my end then the
balls in your court
court and if you mess it up and you and
you you bungle it somehow well then
that's your fault
so mr. Blomgren says that all that
matters is how Lillian green felt no
that's precisely the thing that doesn't
matter that's the only thing in that
situation that doesn't matter what
matters is what what matters for the in
the case of the the bakery two things
matter number one that the store was
closed and number two that the employees
told her that the store was closed
that's literally all that matters those
two things that's the only that's it
precisely the thing that doesn't matter
is how Lilian green felt doesn't matter
how you feel about the fact that the
store is closed
makes no difference whatsoever that is
that's not my job to to somehow protect
your feelings in relation to the fact
that the store is closed what am I
supposed to do what were the employees
supposed to do I mean are we gonna go
they should they take down the number of
every racial minority in the Greater
Portland area and call all of them
individually on the phone before closing
to ask them if it's okay if they close
is that's what their supply guess yes I
guess that's what they're supposed to do
at this point that's that's that's what
is required now if I say hello to you
and you feel like I just called your
mother fat well no I don't know an
apology to your mother because I didn't
say that
now you can claim that yeah you said
hello but what you really meant is that
my mother is fat well you can claim that
and I guess there's a possibility that
you're correct I can't prove you wrong
because you you can't read my mind and I
cannot prove to you what was in my mind
but that is not a reasonable
interpretation of the statement hello
you see it's not something reasonable
for you to assume it yes in there is a
world in which possibly that I mean
someone could say hello and they really
mean it as an insult against your mother
I guess
but all we can do is reasonably
interpret the behaviors and statements
of those around us
um that's all we can do this is not a
reasonable interpretation so I don't
know your apology if I if I tell you
that it's raining outside and you feel
like what I really said was it's
stunning it's sunny out or if I say it's
raining outside but you feel like my
intention was to tell you that it's
sunny and so you walk outside without a
jacket on without it without an umbrella
and you get drenched
the fact that you're dredged is not my
fault your fault I told you
again I did my job
this has become I mean this this is
maybe the number one problem with
with the way
with our communication in those
countries it's it's it's the number one
source of all the miscommunication is
that people think they have the right to
just to to essentially tell you what you
meant by what you said or did that's
what they you say something someone
hears it and that person thinks they
have the right to tell you what you
meant
and if you try to clarify and say no
this is what I really meant it doesn't
matter they'll accuse you of meaning
something and it doesn't matter you
could try to clarify it all you want and
they're safe now it doesn't matter but
how do you know what you meant
I know what you meant you don't know
what you meant who who's gonna be the
authority here on what you were thinking
me are you will obviously me
now
what matters is what is said
and yes the intention behind it
but you cannot impose or abuse Tait Minh
twith it with with unreasonable
intentions or intentions that are
completely disconnected entirely from
what was actually communicated
so now let's let's very quickly you know
an example on the other end of the
spectrum okay an example on the other
end in spectrum let's take the Roseann
situation from a couple days ago so she
tells a joke on Twitter saying that a
black woman is a black woman who was
born in Iran is the love child of the
Muslim Brotherhood and Planet of the
Apes
okay now later she claims that she
didn't mean that to be racist but in
that case it is very reasonable for
people to interpret a comment like that
as racist that in fact is the most
reasonable interpretation of what was
said so in that case even when she comes
back after the fact and says oh yeah I
said something blatantly racist but I
didn't mean it in a racist way well know
that that doesn't work because now
you're being the unreasonable
in that case you said something very
clear your statement was very clear you
said a black woman is the love child of
Planet of the Apes that's a clear
statement and the meaning is very clear
and now you're trying to backtrack later
and you yourself are trying to imbue
that statement with a with a meaning or
an interpretation that is completely
disconnected from what was actually said
so yeah you can't do that either
so like if I say to you your mother is
fat and then later I say no no I just
meant to say hello
well no I can't do that because it's not
what I said if I want to say hello I
should've just said hello
roseann was trying to claim that she's
just trying to say that valerie jarrett
was ugly or something like that she was
trying to make a comment about her looks
which I mean is still not a nice thing
to do but that's not what she said she
could have said Valerie Jarrett looks
funny she's ugly I'm still not a
necessary thing to say but she could
have said that she didn't she said very
specifically
she's from Planet of the Apes so that's
you know races
so we all have a responsibility in this
in this regard to say what we mean and
to use language that clearly conveys our
meaning and as long as we have done
then
we're in the clear
and however people misinterpret it or
whatever they do with it they take it
they put it in a blender they turn you
know they they slice it apart they do
whatever you know they make a
Frankenstein monster out of your
statement
that's all
or at least it should be
all right I think I hope I conveyed my
meaning clearly enough thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
and Godspeed